you
leg of lamb the king of all joints sweet
tender Bay rich absolutely delicious
I must have for every dining table get
your butcher to bone it out and
butterfly it basically so you can tie it
and roast it
hot oven season
Olive Oyl
mint use it in abundance it's fresh it's
fragrant smells amazing goat cheese
the mint perfumes the inside of the lamb
and the goat cheese just sort of makes
the center nice and creamy garlic
Oh
first of all a big loop around the lamb
that key to all these shape
got a nice length of string tie and knot
right the very top underneath and leave
it coming out here the secret I knit
this shape have to cook it evenly and
look useful rosemary
season gets a skin really nice and
crispy olive oil stops a string from
burning so therefore it won't burst open
when it's in the oven
bingo roast that 35 minutes rest carb
mint vinaigrette
that has confirmed it's definitely the
king of roast roast leg of lamb would go
to that mint done the crispy topping you
can see what that deserves to be a great
British classic
banana cheesecake with berry compote
done